tout de suite si je vous demande comme
ça sans trop réfléchir spontanément de
visualiser une seule image qui
représente pour vous assez bien
l'énergie en suisse
à quoi pensez-vous quelle est selon vous
la meilleure illustration de l'énergie
en suisse
je l'entends quelques terne
eh bien il a des chances en effet que
certains parmi vous et pensez à un
barrage en effet c'est une image qui est
très utilisé par les médias qu'on voit
de plus en plus d'ailleurs on parle de
plus en plus aussi de la suisse comme le
château d'eau de l'europe comme si nous
étions capables de produire suffisamment
d'énergie propre et renouvelable pour
alimenter l'entier du continent mais
ceci malheureusement est un pur fantasme
en effet nous consommons près de 80 %
d'énergies non renouvelables de
l'essence et du diesel pour les
véhicules du gaz et du mazout pour
chauffer les bâtiments de l'uranium pour
produire l'électricité nucléaire etc
et cette consommation d'énergie a des
conséquences importantes sur notre
environnement
on peut parler des déchets nucléaires
qui sont produits lors du fonctionnement
normal des centrales nucléaires ou lors
d'accident nucléaire
on peut parler des guerres incessantes
pour les ressources notamment dans les
pays du golfe en irak par exemple on
peut parler des marées noires
on se souvient des pétroliers qui se
sont échoués ou des forages qui ont eu
des fuites comme notamment dans le golfe
du mexique il ya quelques années on peut
parler aussi de la pollution de l'air
qui nous touche particulièrement dans
les villes avec les moteurs à combustion
avec les chaudières
on doit évidemment parler du
réchauffement climatique dont on entend
parler tous les jours dans les médias et
qui est dû principalement vous le savez
aux émissions de co2 donc forcément à la
combustion des énergies fossiles et puis
aussi de la disparition massive des
espèces de l'érosion de la biodiversité
qui est liée en grande partie à ces
facteurs ainsi qu'à d'autres facteurs
comme la destruction des habitats et
surtout par rapport à ces deux derniers
éléments on sait que le temps est compté
l'humanité dans une situation d'urgence
sans précédent on peut dire qu'on a une
sorte de compte à rebours qui est en
marche
on sait qu'on a moins d'une génération
moins d'une génération pour changer
complètement notre manière de produire
et consommer l'énergie et c'est ça qu'on
appelle la transition énergétique
si on veut éviter d'aller dans le mur
comme dans ce dessein on doit tourner le
dos aux énergies
facile et au nucléaire et se tourner
vers les énergies renouvelables
alors la bonne nouvelle il y en a quand
même la bonne nouvelle c'est que cette
transition elle est déjà en marche
en effet vous avez ici la croissance
cumulée de l'énergie éolienne et
photovoltaïque depuis 2005 et on voit
qu'en dix ans en à peine dix ans on a
multiplié par dix la production de ces
nouvelles énergies renouvelables c'est
extrêmement réjouissant c'est même
extraordinaire personne n'avait pu
imaginer ou prédire un tel succès et il
faut naturellement continuer sur cette
voie là mais c'est pas suffisant
pourquoi et bien si on prend en suisse
la consommation d'électricité
il suffit d'une augmentation de
seulement 1 % de notre consommation
d'électricité pour que cela corresponde
à santé au yen donc on peut pas
simplement se contenter d'installer des
nouvelles énergies renouvelables des
panneaux solaires sur les maisons des
éoliennes etc
on doit aussi agir sur la consommation
sinon c'est comme un peu courir derrière
le train ça ne sert à rien et donc nous
devons agir sur deux aspects d'une part
augmenter la quantité d'énergie
renouvelables et d'autre part aussi
jouer sur la consommation c'est-à-dire
stabiliser et diminuer cette
consommation d'énergie et comme vous
l'avez vu le temps est compté on joue
contre la montre on a peu de temps pour
faire ça on doit trouver un moyen très
efficace de le faire rapidement avec
beaucoup d'impact
donc ce qu'on cherche c'est un gros
levier d'accord retenez juste ça pour
l'instant on cherche un gros levier pour
accélérer cette transition énergétique
et la mettre en oeuvre le plus
rapidement possible bien
reprenons à 0 lorsqu'on consomme de
l'énergie on reçoit des factures et ses
factures elles ont été conçus sur la
base de normes légales
en aucun cas pour nous faire prendre
conscience de notre consommation
d'énergie et encore moins pour nous
faire changer de consommation d'énergie
elles sont justes conçu pour répondre à
certaines contraintes légales et
pourtant c'est extrêmement facile de
faire des factures qui soit
compréhensible
vous avez ici quatre indicateurs très
simple que vous pouvez tous comprendre
qui montre le profil d'une consommation
d'un ménage type en suisse par exemple
une famille par exemple 4500
kilowattheures d'électricité ce qui
correspond à 75 francs par mois
ou dans ce cas avec le mix énergétique
de cette famille seulement 3 %
d'énergies renouvelables ce qui est très
faible et environ 450 kg de co2 alors
même si on comprend pas exactement ce
que ça représente ses kilos de co2 mais
c'est relativement facile de comprendre
cette situation il a comparé à une autre
situation comparable à une halte à une
alternative pardon qui serait une option
100% énergies renouvelables 100% hydro
électricité d'origine suisse et ça pour
un franc de plus par mois
cette famille elle pourrait être 100%
renouvelable et réduire drastiquement
ses émissions de co2 alors quand je
pense qu'en suisse on dépense des
centaines de millions dans la recherche
et le développement pour trouver des
nouvelles énergies renouvelables pour
trouver des nouvelles solutions et ici
on a un levier très simple qu'on
pourrait mettre en oeuvre immédiatement
qui coûte rien et je pense qu'on devrait
déjà commencer par là avant de faire des
grandes théories et des grands débats
sur la stratégie énergétique 2050
donc ça c'est un premier levier qu'on
peut utiliser et vous allez me dire
c'est bien joli ça marche peut-être pour
un individu ou une famille mais comment
on fait dans les collectivités publiques
ou dans les entreprises on a des
dizaines infrastructures des dizaines de
bâtiments
on reçoit pour chaque bâtiment une
facture d'eau d'électricité ou des
dizaines de factures d'eau et
d'électricité
donc on perd rapidement la vue
d'ensemble donc c'est très difficile
d'arriver dans une commune est de savoir
par où commencer
j'ai listé ici quelques infrastructures
d'une commune type par exemple de
l'éclairage des écoles une patinoire des
infrastructures sportives et c'est le
genre d'infrastructure qu'on retrouve
dans une commune et si vous êtes élu on
est en période de pré élection si vous
êtes élu en décembre et que vous allez
commencer dans une commune dans cette
commune par quoi vous commencez c'est
difficile d'avoir une vision d'ensemble
rapidement et de mettre en oeuvre des
mesures et de choisir un ou une de ces
infrastructures est de savoir par
laquelle commençait alors pour répondre
à cette question difficile
nous avons développé un logiciel qui va
filtrer les comptes de la commune parmi
des milliers d'écritures comptables qui
va retenir seulement celles qui sont
pertinentes pour l'énergie aie qui va
faire une sorte de tableau de bord
visuel qui va aider à la prise de
décisions et en deux clics on obtient sa
un petit tableau en couleurs sebbar
représente simplement des francs vous
avez en rouge l'électricité en bleu
l'eau et envers le gaz ou le chauffage
vous voyez se dessiner le profil de
consommation énergétique de cette
commune très simplement et vous arrivez
à dire comme ça sans connaître cette
commune sans avoir passé plus de temps à
analyser qu'il ya des éléments qui sont
pas importants par exemple la protection
civile qui apparaît tout en bas et des
éléments qui sont des gros consommateurs
d infrastructures qui sont des gros
consommateurs comme l'éclairage public
qui apparaît tout en haut vous voyez que
c'est une grosse barre rouge c'est une
grosse consommation d'électricité et ça
ça va nous aider à définir des priorités
alors on pourrait dire ok c'est un gros
consommateur mais est ce que cela veut
dire pour autant qu'il ya du potentiel
de réduction ou est-ce que cet éclairage
qui est déjà parfaitement optimisé on
peut rien faire il faut passer au stade
suivant
alors pour répondre à cette question on
peut prendre cette photo où cet ensemble
de photos de la nasa qui montre l'europe
vue du ciel la nuit et qu'est ce qu'on
voit on voit très bien le contour des
pays
on voit très bien les côtes on voit les
grandes villes paris et londres etc et
toute cette lumière qu'on voit depuis
les satellites de la nasa
c'est la lumière qui est perdu c'est de
la lumière qu'on utilise pour éclairer
les étoiles et en gros cette photo c'est
une photo du gaspillage de l'éclairage
public en europe
donc vous voyez comme ça et 8 ivement on
peut on peut imaginer qu'ils aient un
gros potentiel de réduction dans
l'éclairage public et pour en avoir le
coeur net on a développé un logiciel qui
permet de comparer une situation à avec
une situation devait typiquement un
éclairage public d'une certaine rue il
ya dix ans avec le meilleur est à la
technique d'aujourd'hui et on arrive à
voir avec ce logiciel qui simule les
comportements des deux éclairages
publics qu'on arrive à réduire la
facture d'électricité de 85 à 90%
c'est énorme imaginez l'impact sur
l'ensemble de la carte de l'europe ici
donc on a vu que c'est un des gros
consommateurs de la commune et qu'en
plus on peut le réduire de 85 à 90%
donc il ya vraiment un gros potentiel
alors comment on fait ça on est bien
dans notre boîte à outils d'optimisation
on a trois familles d'outils le premier
c'est la sobriété
c'est ce que vous faites tous quand vous
quittez une pièce quand vous quittez
votre maison vous éteignez la lumière
on peut faire la même chose en éclairage
public d'ailleurs il ya de plus en plus
de communes françaises notamment qui
éteignent l'éclairage public entre 1h et
4h du matin ou qui le réduisent
fortement quand y'a personne dans les
rues et ça permet d'économiser de
l'énergie
c'est une mesure qui est facile à mettre
en oeuvre très rapidement mises en
oeuvre
qui permet une bonne rentabilité la
deuxième famille d'outils c'est
l'efficience vous avez tous vu une
étiquette énergie sur les frigos sur les
voitures sur les ampoules etc
on les retrouve partout aujourd'hui et
cette éthique pendant cette étiquette
énergie elle montre quoi elles montrent
qu'on peut fournir la même prestation
avec moins d'énergie
typiquement une nouvelle ampoule elle
produit la même quantité lumière mais
avec moins d'énergie
c'est aussi une mesure qu'on peut mettre
en oeuvre dans l'éclairage public
notamment avec des leds qui vont
consommer moins d'énergie et qui vont
nous permettre de réduire la facture est
la troisième mesure bien sûr c'est les
énergies renouvelables quand on a fait
les deux premières mesures qu'on a
réduit drastiquement la consommation de
cet éclairage par exemple eh bien on
peut l'alimenter alimenté lé solde avec
l'énergie renouvelable et quand on fait
ça quand on fait ses démarches
d'optimisation
c'est un peu comme faire un régime et
quand vous faites un régime
eh bien il faut avoir un objectif et
puis vous allez vous peser régulièrement
et ça aide à maintenir le cap à vous
rendre compte quand vous déviez ou au
contraire vous donner une certaine
motivation pour continuer et dans
l'énergie c'est la même chose
le problème c'est qu'on a tendance à
recevoir des factures annuelles et que
c'est très difficile si vous devez faire
un régime de vous poser une fois par an
donc on a développé un ou plusieurs
logiciels avec de la technique avec ce
qu'on appelle des smart meters qui
permet d'aller relever tous les quarts
d'heure en temps réel des consommations
d'eau d'énergie d'électricité de
chauffage et autres dans les bâtiments
et de visualiser en temps réel
la courbe de consommation alors ici j'ai
pris un exemple un peu atypique avec de
l'eau d'habitude on montre plutôt
l'électricité mais c'est intéressant de
faire avec l'eau et vous voyez que cette
consommation elle fluctue au fur et à
mesure de la journée elle est plus ou
moins normal et tout d'un coup au milieu
de la nuit entre 2h et 4h du matin on a
une explosion de cette consommation
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe si vous
recevez une facture annuelle vous n'avez
aucune chance de déceler çà et là avec
la vision en temps réel vous pouvez voir
tout de suite qui a une consommation qui
se passe est ce que c'est normal est-ce
qu'une fuite
est ce qu'un appareil qui tourne dans le
vide il faudrait investiguer mais avec
ce genre d'outil on a les moyen
d'affiner encore cette optimisation
énergétique et le suivi fin des
consommateurs d'eau et d'énergie alors
ces différents outils que je vous ai
montré on pourrait croire comme ça on a
l'impression de céder pièces du puzzle
sans aucun rapport les unes avec les
autres et ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'en fait on peut les relier dans une
sorte de cercle vertueux
alors on
tout en haut la consommation d'énergie
sur ce cercle et puis à droite on à
comprendre cette facture d'électricité
compréhensible que je vous ai présenté
avant qui permet déjà de d'appréhender
être comprendre sa facture
ensuite on a le tableau de bord en bas à
droite comment définir des priorités sur
la base de l'ensemble de ses factures on
peut voir par exemple que l'éclairage
public est important ensuite on peut
définir des priorités d'action allait
agir optimiser cet éclairage remplacer
les ampoules étendre la nuit etc
et au final on peut suivre finement
cette consommation d'énergie et on a
terminé la boucle on retombe en eau sur
la consommation d'énergie qui aura cette
fois fortement baissé et ce cercle
on peut le faire plusieurs fois d'accord
c'est un cercle d'amélioration continue
et comme ça on peut réduire petit à
petit la consommation d'énergie et si on
versait on se rend compte c'est un peu
le levier qu'on cherchait où c'est en
tout cas un des leviers qu'on pourrait
utiliser pour accélérer cette transition
énergétique et faire quelque chose
d'efficace
la deuxième chose qui est très
intéressante c'est le côté
interdisciplinaire
si on regarde les disciplines où les
thématiques ou les sciences ou savoir
faire qu'on utilise pour faire tous ces
outils dans l'ordre pour la facture on a
utilisé du marketing de la psychologie
des normes légales de l'électricité pour
les priorités on a utilisé un tableau de
bord on a utilisé de l'ergonomie on a
utilisé du datamining on a utilisé de
l'informatique etc pour les priorités
d'action on utilise toutes les sciences
de l'ingénieur l'optimisation les
énergies renouvelables et puis
poursuivre on a de la télémétrie on a
des télécoms on as de l'informatique etc
et pour mettre en oeuvre toute cette
boucle d'amélioration continue eh bien
on a du management et j'arrive au
message que je voulais vous transmettre
ce soir c'est que d'une part cette
consommation d'énergie vous cette
transition énergétique
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important c'est une grosse menace un
gros défi que nous devons relever et je
pense que nous devons pas attendre ne
vont pas être paralysé et attendre qu'un
chercheur quelque part invente une
nouvelle méthode ou une nouvelle énergie
propre infinie gratuite etc
non je pense que chacun de nous
consommons de l'énergie
chacun nous avant un petit levier sur
cette consommation énergétique et tous
quel que soit quelques nous soyons
quel que soit notre position sociale
quelle que soit notre couleur politique
notre profession nous pouvons agir sur
cette consommation d'énergie faciliter
cette transition énergétique contribue à
écrire cette histoire de la transition
énergétique et faire en sorte qu'elle se
termine par une happy end
merci